we're now looking at the second essay
Friedrich Nietzsche is genealogy of
morals yeah there's a few things that I
want to say about this this essay and
how to read it and where we're going
with this before actually going into the
content of the section so this is right
in the middle you know the first and the
third the third is a much larger portion
and each one of the essays deals with
one sort of set of issues or problems
now they are all connected together and
each one is in fact a genealogy so you
might say it's not just the genealogy of
morals it's a whole bunch of genealogies
put together yeah what does that mean
well if you think about a genealogy I
said this in the first video
Nietzsche doesn't mean it in the sense
of just going back to a family origin a
beginning point in the family tree of
things he's looking for something more
like the ancient sense of genealogy
where you actually said where things
came from what their Genesis their
origin was because they would tell you
something about them and would also
allow you a comparison between that and
the present-day conceptions that we have
these things and Nietzsche's work here
is to some degree polemical that means
that he's engaging with other people who
have had things to say about the very
phenomena that he's talking about and
he's taking different positions he's
taking positions that say no they've
actually misunderstood these phenomena
there's a deeper history a deeper
meaning something more complex something
more interesting in some respects going
on so another thing I would like to say
before we actually begin since this is a
a series that is is framed in terms of
existentialism we want to think about
what does nietzsche aiming after in in
this piece what is what is he actually
doing from the perspective
something beyond just just you know
historical problems something that might
address where we are today
well Nietzsche is telling a story and
we're gonna go into that story in just a
moment he's telling a story that has a
lot of different portions to it a lot of
different interweaving parts and this
story is in large respect about where
our moral ideas came from these ideas
that we use whether we like it or not to
sort of articulate our bearings in the
world with other people in relation to
ourselves and he's telling it at a point
in time which doesn't look that much
different from from our own point in
time where Nietzsche thinks that the
biggest problem on the horizon is what
we could call Niall is 'm which is
humanity becoming weary of its itself
I'm getting caught within its its own
kind of traps finding itself in a kind
of dead end where it just spins around
and so it comes to a kind of pessimism a
kind of meaninglessness and he wants to
contra pose to that something else and
and there's a lot of you know legitimate
controversy about well what exactly is
that something else is it a reversion
back to previous times this kind of
noble you know blond beast barbarian
coming through and imposing order or is
it something a little bit more complex
well that's that's something we're going
to talk about at the end of this essay
so I don't want to give that give that
away quite yet what I do want to say too
before going into this is two other
important things so he's interested in
this historical problem right and you
can see a lot of what's going on
throughout this piece articulated in
terms of the question of origins versus
the question
purposes that's gonna be a main theme
that we'll get to not too long in he's
starting out by asking about you know
what is the kind of being that can
actually make promises we take this for
granted all too often when we're
thinking about human beings because we
don't take a historical perspective as
Nietzsche sees himself doing as a matter
of fact even the people who thought that
they were taking a historical
perspective in his view were not
actually being historical enough that is
they were not actually tracing things
back far enough they were not actually
confronting the kind of ugly truths
about things as they they originally
took place and they also lack the right
kind of metaphysical framework to make
make sense out of that but this is a
major theme what how is it that human
beings actually become responsible
develop something that we call the
conscience the other really big theme
running throughout this is the notion of
punishment and I'm not going to go as
deeply into this as I could in this
video and part because I want to keep
the narrative moving along I'm going to
be shooting another core concept video
specifically on this this section about
punishment looking at it a little bit
more closely another key issue is the
guilty conscience how does the guilty
conscience actually arise where does the
sense of guilt come from and guilt and
the guilty conscience are not exactly
the same thing as we're going to see in
this development but eventually the
guilty conscience leads to this
situation of nihilism something that
Nietzsche wants to first of all
conceptualize make sense out of figure
out how did we actually get here how did
we end up at this dead end and then he
wants to try to figure how do we get out
of this how do we break through the
cultural situation of niall ISM another
point another key theme that's going to
come through here that actually the
first thing that I'm going to talk about
looking at
in terms of content is that what we call
the will to power a common theme running
throughout all of Nietzsche's ideas
works movements everything that he's
about the will to power is as
Heidegger's point at putting it out sort
of the key to his metaphysics and it's
tied in here in this work with the
notion of freedom and with the instincts
so we have to explore that in just a
moment but before we do that the second
thing that I want to point out again
what we're dealing with with a genealogy
is a narrative now nietzsche uses a key
term which you may not be familiar with
i'm not actually sure where comes from
originally but that you see it in
semiotic the study of signs the study of
language the study of communication and
you also see it in psychiatry and
psychoanalysis this notion of
overdetermined overdetermined this
thing's actually having too much meaning
piled into them it's a kind of ambiguity
where something is you might say super
charged with being able to be read in so
many different ways and why so many
different ways because it legitimately
has all these different aspects to it
reality is over determined it's complex
it's not so simple as many of the the
narratives about it make it out to be
so the narratives about moral phenomena
the sorts of things like responsibility
action right and wrong good and bad good
and evil all these sorts of concepts
that we use every single day and can't
get away from even if we want it to any
more than we can get away from notions
like truth or being in general when you
have a narrative about them that
narrative is going to be for somebody
like Nietzsche over determined that
means there's a lot of different things
coming in so the caution that I want to
make from the start is it's easy
see a lot of those discussions as being
about just like two classes of people
you know the strong and the weak but
really there's a lot more going on here
the strong develop in certain ways
there's different types of strengths
different you know types of strong
people appearing in history they do have
the will to power in common but each
will to power is not some sort of you
know instance of some eternal in a will
to power out their existing like a
platonic form it's an actually existing
will to power and each one is going to
look rather different from from others
same thing with different weak human
beings weak human animals as Nietzsche
would see them they're not all the same
they differ at different points in
history so let's start out with this
notion of the will to power this is
particularly interesting but also very
important for understanding what's going
on here so we're going to begin in in
the the end of section 11 so you know
but halfway through he's talking about
justice and injustice and and we'll come
back to this this you know notional
later I don't want to focus on that what
I want to focus on is this passage
that's very often quoted where he says
life operates essentially that is in its
basic functions through injury assault
exploitation destruction and simply
cannot be thought of at all without this
character so the will to power is
intimately connected with life and what
does life involve get rid of all of this
now I'm going to keep this up here the
will to power
the will the power is a fundamental
aspect of life and life is fundamentally
about exploitation about dominance also
about desire
Nietzsche sees this as integral to two
things you know even even plants which
we might think of as a you know the most
passive of organisms break other things
down and assimilate them some plants are
actually parasitic on other plants
animals animals destroy plants or other
animals in order to exist in order to
feed and it goes beyond that you know
horses will get together and they
establish dominance hierarchies even
though they're a herd animal they'll
bite each other and kick each other and
things like like that we start getting
to the more top food chain animals and
we start seeing even more of this this
kind of activity so he says one must
indeed grant something even more
imperative all that from the highest
biological standpoint legal conditions
can never be anything other than
exceptional conditions since they
constitute a partial restriction of the
will to life which is bent upon power so
power and life are intimately
interconnected for for Nietzsche and you
might actually instead of just putting a
- or an equal sign all right and he says
what is this what is this power about he
says the will to life bent upon power
and are subordinated to its total goal
as a single means namely as a means of
creating greater units of power so this
is another really important feature of
the will to power the will to power
works by taking in other things each of
which
has its own will to power because what
is it to live to exist to be for for
Nietzsche it is to be active and to be
active means to act upon something else
that means to cause something else to
suffer to subordinate something else to
make oneself the higher thing and
another thing the lower thing to to
force it in some ways well you know to
be a dominant will to power means to
assimilate things and to force these
other things into subordination to make
them fit what it is that you want them
to be to do to become so that's a very
important point that he's making there
let's go ahead a little bit more and
let's look at a few other things he says
about the will to power and I'm going to
come back to this notion of function of
a woman let's look at the very end of
the chapter chapter 12 right after that
he says that a major point of historical
method is that it's in fundamental
opposition to the now prevalent instinct
and taste which would rather be
reconciled even to the absolute
fortuitous Ness even the mechanistic
senselessness of all events then to the
theory that in all events a will to
power is operating now you know some
people want to read Nietzsche because
he's an atheist and say ah perfect fits
in great with evolutionary biology with
Darwin with any of this sort of stuff
well if you have a mechanistic
conception of that sort of thing
something that would be reducta Balad
into complete confidence with some sort
of mathematical model nature would say
no that's not what we're talking about
the will to power has life is always
going to be unpredictable it's always
going to go be
on your models your algorithms whatever
it is that you're trying to work out
mechanistically mechanistically means in
some way that it could be reduced to a
machine so if your view of human beings
is that our brains are basically like
computers and you know we have these you
know systems with neurons and then
hormones and you know external stimuli
coming in if that's your kind of
viewpoint then actually that's not
compatible with what nietzsche is
putting forth here Nietzsche says
there's a democratic idiosyncrasy which
opposes everything that dominates and
wants to dominate the modern Miss
archaism that he says to coin an ugly
word for an ugly thing has permeated the
realm of the Spirit and disguised itself
in the most spiritual forms to such a
degree that the day it has forced its
way it's acquired the right to force its
way into the strictest apparently most
objective Sciences and he sees this in
terms of his own contemporaries in
biology psychology I think he would say
this of sociologists that they all end
up treating human beings in ways that
ignore this fundamental ground of the
will to power and this is present not
only in human beings this is present
also in every kind of living being it
establishes a kind of continuum between
us and the other animals so he goes on a
little bit further and he says in people
like Herbert Spencer or other people who
are talking about evolution and
annotation one of the things that
they're ignoring by focusing on
annotation adaptation is reactive for
nature reactive means that something
else is coming in and it's either on the
same level as you or it is higher than
you and you're only reacting to it
this is active to subordinate other
things to yourself to exercise power on
them that is is active he says the
essence of life it's will to power is
ignored
once one overlooks the essential
priority of the spontaneous aggressive
expansive form giving forces that give
new interpretations and directions
although adaptation follows only after
this so biological adaptation you the
very notion of evolution the way many
people have it or use it you know the
kind of ideological function that it has
for them I need you differs from that
Nietzsche is saying no real change the
most important change doesn't take place
because things merely react to their
environment or to other conditions being
placed upon them or some higher being
and it forces them to go a certain way
it's because they forced something on to
those other beings there is an exercise
of power perhaps even greater and
greater and greater power going on with
that so that's important to to think
about and this is going to lead us now
to another point which which I want to
go into which again is in the middle of
this and we'll come back to a coherent
narrative in just a moment but he talks
about punishment and you notice I left
here this origins versus purpose issue
Nietzsche says that origins are one
thing purpose is another thing these are
two problems that are separate and
people are usually mixing these up what
does he mean by that he means that
people you know sit in their their
armchair and they think to themselves
well you know what is the purpose of
this thing and if we figure out what the
purpose of that is well it's a human
created thing an idea or a tool or a
piece of technology or an institution if
we figure out what its purpose is and
maybe it has a whole set of purposes so
we pick its highest purpose
then we actually know why people came up
with that in the first place so you know
think about for instance a picture frame
okay a picture frame is pretty simple
why did people come up with a picture
frame well you know see you could hang
pictures of it and it's got a particular
function which is to protect it from the
outside but maybe that's not its most
important function maybe it's to frame
it so that we're not just looking at the
whole wall and then like oh there's a
picture we actually find out our view
centered on that is that what the origin
was maybe it was just to protect the
thing and maybe all this embellishments
and all this this other stuff that goes
along with it
that's all extra stuff that came later
that's all purposes to be sure those are
legitimate purposes but those are not
necessarily the origin now let's think
about something you know much deeper
like say marriage what is the purpose of
marriage well you know that's pretty
complex there's a lot of different
answers to that question and we're not
gonna try to explore those here I just
want to point out that there's a lot of
available answers to that you know
running from well just you know in
conscience sort of form having access to
each other's body or sexuality or
something like that all the way to
development of intimacy you know a much
more elevated conception of marriage
nature actually talks about this at a
certain point in the genealogy and he
says you know in ancient times you
almost had to make up to the Society for
the fact that you were taking this with
a very male center view taking a woman
out of circulation so to speak and
appropriating you know her solely to
yourself you had to you know make it
worth the community's while well that's
a very different conception as well or
any of those necessarily why marriage
came on the scene
that's the origin not necessarily what
about punishment why do we punish that's
a very interesting question and that
leads to this this this issue of over
determination you know nature comes up
with a whole bunch of different reasons
why one might punish in chat in in
section 13 of this and I'm not even sure
how many I would say about 15 different
reasons that you just rattle off well
that means that punishment could be
given a lot of different possible
purposes what's the origin of punishment
though it's not nature says just simply
make people feel bad to it to evoke a
guilty conscience of them he actually
says we're going back to the will the
power with this one imagine that
punishment was designed devised for
punishing right for doing something to
other people and what was it what was
the purpose of it he says purposes and
utilities are only signs that a will to
power has become master of something
less powerful and imposed upon it the
character of a function and the entire
history of a thing an organ a custom can
in this way be a continuous sign chain
of ever new interpretations and
adaptations whose causes do not even
have to be related to one another but on
the contrary in some cases succeed in
alternated with one another in purely
chance fashion the evolution of a thing
he says a custom an organ is thus by no
means a part of progress towards a goal
it's not teleological in the sense that
there's some sort of internal necessity
driving it forward the way that you know
Hegel thought or Aristotle thought or
tought thought or Thomas Aquinas thought
even less illogical progresses by the
shortest route and with the smallest
expenditure of force but a succession of
more or less profound more or less
mutually independent processes of
subduing
of action of something imposing itself
on something else plus the resistance is
that they encounter the attempts of
transformation for the purposes of
defense and reaction and the results of
successful counter actions so Nietzsche
talks about all these things are moral
concepts they are our activities our
institutions including that of
punishment as things which can change
over time not only in their application
not only in their existence but in their
very meaning in the meaning thats
accorded to them because what actually
gives them the meaning that they have
somebody deciding to impose that and if
society has a certain given meaning at a
certain point or you you know you join a
discipline you know say sociology and
this particular in a style of sociology
that you're studying says the purpose of
punishment is this then you're accepting
sort of the sedimented will to power
that that's imposed upon that let's go
on now and let's go back to the very
beginning and I'm going to skim through
this somewhat just hitting on certain
points because we're not gonna be able
to cover everything in this grade of
death she asked how do you breathe in
the animal with the right to make
promises and he's got this great set of
reflections on forgetfulness you know in
certain respects it's healthy to forget
things to not take them to heart now on
the other hand if you forget things you
also become kind of a danger to other
people particularly if you have to live
next to them you know if you forget that
you shouldn't burn their house down or
take their things or that third things
are there things you're going to
actually get them Kenney irritated with
you and he says you know responsibility
originated by breeding an animal with
the right to make promises the ability
to actually exercise force
upon itself so there's there's an
internal dynamic there there's a
spontaneity that gets lost in in the
process and she says if we actually look
at you know sort of the the prehistory
of the human race the prehistoric labor
he calls it the greater part of
existence of humanity it's great
justification notwithstanding the
severity tyranny stupid stupidity and
idiocy involved in it is that man is
made calculable it's something you can
rely upon calculable when I look at
other people and within myself as well
so he says if we place ourselves at the
end of this tremendous process where the
tree lately at last brings forth fruit
then we discover that the ripe is fruit
is a sovereign individual like only to
himself liberated again for the morality
of custom autonomous and here he says
something really interesting super moral
above morality for autonomous and moral
or mutually exclusive he says in short
the man who has his own independent
protracted will and the right to make
conscious promises the master of a free
will now he doesn't think that this is
everybody by any means in our society or
in his society that we're all this you
know a great master but this is
something that came about through this
transformation this is different than
the the you know master who's the blond
beast who comes in and you know crushes
everything and subordinates everything
and remakes things there's a constancy
afforded there
what is this talks about this proud
awareness of the extraordinary privilege
of responsibility the consciousness of
this rare freedom the power over oneself
and over fate the capacity to actually
is important the capacity to actually
use one's will to power not only to
dominate other beings but reflexively
the capacity to control oneself that's
what's required to make promises that's
what's required to have responsibility
now you can have this by being you know
in this elevated super moral class or
you can have this in other ways where
other things have gonna force this upon
you and he goes on and he says this is
what we call conscience now conscience
means very different things for the
masters and for the inferiors for nature
let's go on he talks about the need for
what he calls NAB no technics the the
techniques of producing memory he says
if something is to stay in the memory it
must be burned in only that which never
ceases to hurt stays in the memory this
is a main clause of the oldest
psychology on earth and he says it's
it's still effective man could never do
without blood torture and sacrifices
when he felt the need to create a memory
for himself the most dreadful sacrifices
and pledges the most repulsive
mutilations the cruelest rites of all
religious cults all this has its origin
and the instinct that realized that pain
is the most powerful aid to dynamics so
one of the things that's required in
order to have this self mastery is also
to have memory and in order to have
memory you have to have pain suffering
and like I said this can come in in part
by dominating one's self by developing
self-control or it can come in by
somebody else intervening a greater and
forcing this upon
you know the slave for example who has
to watch out so that they don't get
themselves in trouble and thereby
develop self-control does so not because
they exercise self mastery in the same
sense as the completely free individual
does they they develop that because
somebody else forces that upon them now
he goes on and he starts talking about
punishment
where did punishment come from he says
and why is he interested so interested
in punishment
well because guilt and Punishment are
inextricably tied together they are two
moral concepts that in some respects
stem from each other so he asks this how
did the somber thing the consciousness
of guilt the bad conscience come into
the world well we have to look at how
people were punished originally and what
was the mindset of people punishing them
did were they being punished and make
them accountable to try to awaken in
that in this sense and oh I did the
wrong thing I chose to do the wrong
thing I could have chose him to do
something else I'd better fix myself and
change my ways it says no as a matter of
fact if you if you look at ancient tax
and the way that the punishment has
talked about it's talked about less like
that you know the criminal deserves
punishment because he could have acted
differently says that's very late that
doesn't that doesn't occur early on the
the psychologist that he's criticizing
thought that that was the deal
but he says throughout the greater part
of human history punishment was not
imposed because one held the wrongdoer
responsible for the deed less not on the
presupposition that only guilty one
should be punished rather his parents
punished their children from anger from
anger at some harm or injury vented on
the one who caused it punishment is
actually an exercise of the will to
power reactively against somebody else
who's irritated oneself but this anger
is held in check and modified by the
idea
that every injury has its equivalent and
can actually be paid back if only
through the pain of the culprit very
interesting thing here so if it was just
pure rage the rage would demolish the
object instead through punishment some
sort of something is imposed not only
something that one doesn't like but a
whole framework of interpretation you
steal from me therefore I'm gonna make
you suffer and I'm gonna make you suffer
in this way because I get to do that I
get to take exactly this much from you
in this way or this way or this way
that's an interpretation that's being
forced upon somebody and he says what is
this rooted in the idea of creditor and
debtor the debtor I should put this on
the board the debtor is the guilty party
the one who owes so the original
relationship as soon as we have society
its creditor and debtor the debtor owes
the creditor can call back or has given
and the debtor owes something now what
punishment is is forcing the debtor to
pay back something that they actually
owe and the creditor or the society
itself is the one who decides what is
with the actual terms are now like he
says this is a contractual relationship
old is the idea of legal subjects when
we contemplate these contractual
relationships he says we feel
considerable suspicion and repugnance
towards those men of the past who
created or permitted them why well
because anything went you could sell
your children into slavery you could
sell yourself into slavery
you could agree to be beaten to be you
know humiliated all sorts of things and
that is it in fact what happened to
people who went into death you know
Athens became a democracy in part by
reaction against what it was that the
creditors were imposing on the debtors
so like he says let's be clear as to the
logic of this form of compensation that
equivalence is provided by the creditors
receiving in place of a literal
compensation for an injury that's in
place of money land possession of any
kind recompense in the form of a kind of
what pleasure
so the creditor gets pleasure from the
debtor why does the why does the
creditor get pleasure from the debtors
the creditor you know now do they have a
debtor who just sort of hangs around and
you know plays music for them or
entertains them or you know caters to
their needs you know whether they be
food or sacks or whatever no it's
because they actually get to impose
suffering so suffering and pleasure are
intimately interconnected in this he
says what kind of pleasure is the
pleasure of being allowed to vent his
power freely upon one who is powerless
the voluptuous pleasure to fear them off
with a phaser to the fair which is to do
evil to do wickedness to do harm to
somebody for the very enjoyment of doing
it
Nietzsche is tying in with something
that is is very deep within human nature
very deeper than even animal nature
itself particularly for the higher
animals there is a tendency towards a
kind of sadism towards a kind of
experimental injury to
and human beings have to pass through
this as a matter of fact part of
becoming well integrated is learning not
to do this to people you know and to
actually feel bad when you when you do
it and to make recompense so you know
somebody harms you in the ancient times
they get to know you get to now harm
them you get to make them suffer in turn
so he says in punishment and punishing
the debtor the creditor participates in
something the creditor becomes the
master they get to exercise their will
to power on the other person and he says
it was in this sphere then the sphere of
legal obligations at the moral
conceptual world of guilt conscience
Duty had its origins its beginnings were
like the beginnings of everything great
on earth soaked in blood thoroughly and
for a long time and might one not add
that fundamentally this world has never
since lost a certain order of blood and
torture so guilt and suffering are
interconnected and he says to the extent
that to make suffer was in the highest
degree pleasurable to the extent that
the injured party exchanged for the loss
he had sustained including the
displeasure caused by the loss and
extraordinary counterbalancing pleasure
they had of making suffer a genuine
festival something which as a person was
surprised the more highly the more
violently it contrasted with the rank
and social standing of the creditor so
the more lowly the creditor was in the
social hierarchy the more pleasure they
get out of out of imposing that because
it makes them feel like they're a master
and you know if you look at descriptions
that people give people who have engaged
in statistic behavior war atrocities
things like that one of the things that
you you see coming up over and over
again is them saying it made me feel
alive it made me feel a greater sense of
vitality we're not as far away from this
as we as we'd often like to think
cruelty is not something
radically foreign to our nature it's
something that we need to actually think
about to actually come to know because
it's always lurking there so he goes on
and he says I'm gonna skip over this
he's talking about suffering he makes a
digression here and he says suffering is
brought forth is the principle argument
against existence
and he's gonna contrast the modern I
should put this on the board to is
suffering meaningful the ancient Greek
conception of suffering so I like this
the Christian conception of suffering
also saw meaning and suffering the
modern after God has taken out of the
picture because you know after all God
is dead according to Nietzsche oh that
is the idea of God no longer has its
function anymore for the moderns
suffering constitutes a problem that it
didn't for the ancients or for Christian
Europe and and I would say that this
might actually apply if Nietzsche you
know thought a little bit more through
this to other areas were the other main
world religions had kind of health so he
says what really aroused his indignation
against suffering is not suffering as
such but the self the senselessness of
suffering why did the Christians see
senselessness he interpreted a whole
mysterious machinery of salvation into
it nor for the naive man a more ancient
times who understood all suffering in
relation to the spectator of it or the
clause or of it was there any such thing
as senseless suffering so there wasn't
any need to worry about that in modern
times we worry about senseless suffering
we don't know why people have to suffer
well you know Nietzsche would say we
have to suffer in part because the will
to power is what drives everything
and sooner or later somebody is gonna
have to suffer and somebody who's going
to make somebody suffer so let's go on
he says to return to our ves
investigation the feeling of guilt of
personal obligation had its origin in
the oldest and most primitive personal
relationship between buyer and seller
creditor and debtor it was here that one
person first encountered another person
that one person first measured himself
against another so what's going on here
is a you know mankind learning about
what it is to be human
through this this activity of measuring
oneself against things he goes on and he
talks about two other things that have
this this sort of form creditor versus
daddy now one of these I should probably
this so this can be the individual human
being as a creditor in which case we're
dealing with if we're talking about
punishment what we would call revenge
retribution those sorts of things but
the creditor can also be society or the
state and then if somebody offends
against Society or offends against the
state they're treated as if they
violated another creditor and the
creditor gets to make them pay and that
creditor actually has a lot more force
at their disposal don't they so he talks
about the community and he says as power
increases the community then gets to
punish the law breaker the law breaker
is a debtor who has not merely failed to
make good the advantages and advanced
payments restored upon him but has
actually attacked his creditor therefore
he's not only deprived of those
advantages and benefits he's also
reminded through cruelty through
imposition of punishment what these
benefits are really worth the wrath of
the disappointed creditor the community
throws him back into the savage and
outlaw state against which he has
hitherto been protected
now this changes over time as as the
community becomes stronger and stronger
it actually becomes more humane and the
reason it becomes more humane like you
says is it can actually afford to allow
some things to slide it doesn't have to
punish as much I'm gonna skip ahead a
little bit he talks about another case
another type of structure like this in
terms of religion the ancestors there's
there's a there's a sort of going
through into time and he says within the
original tribal community the living
generation always recognized at Girod
jeredy juridical sorry duty towards
early generally er generations
especially towards the earliest which
founded the tribe the conviction reigns
that it's only through the sacrifices
and accomplishments of the ancestors
that the tribe exists and that one has
to pay them back with sacrifices and
accomplishments so within the society
it's not just you know to the present
society it's to the past generations of
ancestors one recognizes a debt that
constantly grows greater why does the
debt grow greater because the better
things get for you the more those
ancestors must have set things up well
for you and he says the fear of the
ancestor is power the consciousness of
indebtedness to him increases according
to this kind of logic in exactly the
same measure as the power of the tribe
increases as the tribe itself grows ever
more victorious independent honoured and
feared if one imagine this rude kind of
logic carried to its end then the
ancestors of the most powerful tribes
are bound eventually to grow to
monstrous dimensions through the
imagination of growing fear and to
recede into the darkness of the divinely
uncanny and imagined
what are we talking about here we are
talking about religion and the gods so
the creditor cannot only be the
individual human being it can be these
larger things that affect everybody and
he goes on and and it's very interesting
here he says even as mankind inherited
the concepts good and bad from the
tribal nobility along with his basic
basic psychological propensity some
orders of rank it also inherited along
with the tribal and family divinities
the burden of still unpaid debts and had
the desire to be relieved of them and
then he talks about Christianity as
being sort of like the maximal example
of this the advent of the Christian God
is the maximum God attains so far that's
a really interesting thing to say
Nietzsche is not against Christianity
just because you know we want to screw
with the Christians or something like
that he sees Christianity as in a
certain respect the most successful
exercise of the will to power in history
in a reactive way but an inventive way
that creates this maximal God that
surpasses all of the others any and then
he says you know since Christianity is
you know broken down basically and
remember he's writing this about a
hundred and fifty years in the past
he says presuming we have gradually
entered on the reverse course there's no
small probability it's with the
irresistible decline of faith in the
Christian God there is now also a
considerable decline of mankind's
feeling of guilt
indeed the prospect cannot be dismissed
that the complete in the definitive
victory of atheism might free mankind of
this whole feeling of guilty
indebtedness towards its origin atheism
in a kind of second innocence belong
together he's saying this at the end of
section 20 and now if you look at
section 21 he says yeah but that's not
the way it actually works
atheism didn't the the death of God
didn't
we free us from guilt didn't actually
free us from this entire cycle and he
says why because we moralize the
concepts of guilt and duty they're
pushed back into the band conscience
this actually involves an attempt to
reverse the direction of this
development described above the aim now
is to preclude pessimistically once and
for all the prospect of a final
discharge the aim now is to make the
glance recoil disconsolately from an
iron impossibility the aim now is to
turn back the concepts guilt and Duty
back against whom against who well
against the debtor and against any sort
of creditor and this is Neill ISM modern
atheism didn't free mankind from
Christianity and from all the the
effects of that in part because of the
bad conscience Nietzsche would say that
the majority of modern atheists are
themselves infected with bad conscience
so now we actually have to find out what
what is this bad conscience so we have
to skip back a little bit and he says
punishment doesn't actually make us
better what it does one of the effects
that it has is to make us turn inward it
makes us pull up short it makes us think
twice about what we're doing now how
does that get us to the bad comments
well the bad conscience arises because
the will to power which wants to
exercise itself upon other things is
checked limited
and then was it do it turns in on itself
it creates space inside the soul
Nietzsche says all instincts that do not
discharge themselves outwardly turn
inward this is what I've called the
internalization of man thus it was that
man first developed what was later
called his soul the entire inner world
originally is thin if it were stretched
between two membranes expanded and
extended itself acquired depth breadth
and height in the same measure as
outward charge was inhibited so how is
our charge inhibited well by laws by
society by religion by something else
saying no or you must do this and the
more that went on the more inwardness
developed because these these instincts
were hemmed in and he says the fearful
Baal works with which the political
organization protected itself against
the old instincts of freedom punishment
among these ball works brought about
that all these instincts of wild free
prowling man turned backwards against
man himself hostility what does he mean
these instincts well some of these
instincts are the instinct to take you
no pleasure in making somebody else
suffer hostility cruelty joy in
persecuting and attacking in in change
in destruction all this turned against
the possessors of such instincts that he
says is the origin of bad conscience
the man who from lack of external
enemies and resistances and forcibly
confined to the oppressive narrowness
Ness and Punk chilliest miss of custom
impatiently lacerated persecuted gnawed
and assaulted and maltreated himself
this is the invention of the
conscience and he says let's add that
the existence on earth of an animal soul
turned against itself taking sides
against itself was something so new
profound unheard-of
enigmatic contradictory and pregnant
with the future this is an advance an
advance in a certain way it looks like
it's just a decline but things are
opening up inside this is something
beyond what the raw barbarians who you
know just you know I mean I'm good
you're bad
I imposed my force on you they're kind
of superficial and shallow compared to
this so he says from now on man is
included among the most unexpected and
exciting lucky throws and the the dice
game of Heraclitus is great child as if
man were not only a goal but away an
episode a bridge a great promise and
Nietzsche said something else that's
really interesting
listen section 17 he says the change
referred to is not a gradual or
voluntary one and did not represent an
organic adaptation to new conditions but
a break a leap a compulsion and in a
look table disaster which precluded all
struggle and even all rosante mouths so
what's going on with his bad conscience
he goes on he talks about this a little
bit more about the instinct of freedom
and he says eventually this is a imposed
at first by the need for political order
but then it gets imposed by self itself
one goes beyond what society requires
from one and imposes this sort of
limitation upon oneself he says it's the
same active force that it's work on a
grander scale in those artists of
violence and organizers who build States
and that here internally on a smaller
and pettier scale directed backwards in
the labyrinth of the breasts to as
Goethe's expression creates for itself a
bad conscience and builds negative
ideals the instinct for freedom or is in
my language the will to power he says
the nature of this force events itself
man itself is whole ancient animal self
and not in that greater and more obvious
phenomenon some other man other men
this secret self ravishing this artist
cruelty was delighted imposing a form
upon one's self as the hard recalcitrant
suffering material and in burning a will
a critique a contradiction to contempt a
no into it this uncanny dreadful
dreadful a joyous labor of a soul
voluntarily at odds with itself that
makes itself suffer out of joy and
making itself suffer this becomes the
bad conscience
so everything ascetic you know whether
it's Christian asceticism Platonism pick
whatever you like it always involves
trying to master oneself trying to make
oneself do something trying to control
oneself taking a secret delight and
imposing something upon oneself that's
the origin and that's the continuation
and that's the growth of this bad
conscience that Nietzsche talks about so
to go on a little bit further towards us
towards the very end from this he says
that will the self tormenting that
repressed cruelty of the animal man-made
inward and scared back into himself
the creature imprisoned in the state so
as to detained who invented the bad
conscience why so that he could hurt
himself it certainly people you know
cutting themselves so that they can get
something out of it right after the more
natural events where this desire to hurt
had been blocked the man of bad
conscience is seized upon the
presupposition of religion so as to
drive his self torture to its most
gruesome pitch of severity and rigor
guilt before God so that's one
particular frame of the the guilty
conscience and Nietzsche is going to ask
at the very end he says we modern men
are the heirs of the conscience
vivisection and self torture of
millennia man is all too long had an
evil eye for his natural inclinations
for you know dominance for free
consuming for expropriating that they
finally become inseparable from his bad
conscience and attempt at the reverse
would in itself be possible who is
strong enough for it that is to Wed the
bad conscience not to the natural urges
for sex for dominance for consuming for
forming but rather to all the unnatural
inclinations all those aspirations to
the beyond so that which run counter to
sense instinct nature animal in short to
all ideals hitherto which are all one
which are all which are one and all
hostile to life and ideals it slander
the world to whom when one turn today
with such hopes and demands so he's
saying can we take this this this bad
conscience this sort of tendency to like
hurt ourselves to impose force upon
ourselves can we take it away from those
natural drives and instincts and turn it
instead against those things sort of
turn the bad conscience inward upon
itself and make it push
and he says is this even possible today
the attainment of this goal would
require a different kind of spirit from
that likely to appear in this present
page spirits strengthened by war and
victory for whom conquest adventure
danger and even pain have become needs
we would require habituation to the Keen
air of the heights to which of journeys
to ice and mountains in every sense it
would require even a kind of sublime
wickedness an ultimate Sabri meant
supremely self-confident mischievousness
and knowledge that goes with great
health it would require in brief and
lasts precisely this great health so
Nietzsche is not saying that he himself
is doing this nature wasn't a healthy
guy by the way you know physically or
mentally but he's laying out an ideal
and he's saying can we get away from
where we've ended up in this long
history and produce something new not
something that's a reversion to the past
but something that's a yet even further
permutation on the bad conscience where
the bad conscience that ire that you
know self laceration gets turned on
ideals rather than on instincts so he
says the man of the future who will
redeem us not only from the hitherto
reigning ideal but also from that which
was bound to grow out of it and here he
says the grand nausea the will to
nothingness nihilism he calls us the
anti-christ and anti nihilist
that's interesting Nietzsche is not
Neela's Nietzsche is arguing everything
he can to try to get us out of what he
sees as niall ism he says this victor
over God and nothingness he must come
one day and this is an interesting idea
well this is what we'll close with that
pretty soon give it long enough any sort
of new complication of human beings that
can come on the scene will in fact come
on the scene and it will through
somebody asserting their will to power
to say
I'm gonna do something different this
will not be what I take I will do this
instead
so Nietzsche's not saying just you know
get rid of the bad conscience altogether
and everything's gonna be okay and
you'll be authentic or something like
that she's saying that somehow you have
to actually get beyond the bad
conscience and it probably helps quite a
bit to understand the origin of the bad
conscience and how I came about if we
want us to extricate one's self from it
so he's laid out for us an entire story
here I've skipped over a few portions
and parts but I will have other shorter
videos which discuss those in particular
punishment itself and next we're going
to continue with the final third essay
in this great work the genealogy of
morals